in der letzten folge finger weg wurde
handy aus der schau rausgeschmissen und
dann wurden drei neue leute in die schau
mit reingepackt ich bin gespannt wie das
ganze heute die gruppendynamik verändern
wird denn herzlich willkommen hier heute
mal wieder zu einer neuen reaktion von
mir auch vor ort zu händeln er das kann
ja heiter werden die neuen sind keine
zehn minuten hier und haben david messi
und glory schon den kopf verdreht ich
krass unsere lampe strahlt mal wieder
ich bin echt gespannt ob da jetzt regeln
gebrochen werden mal sehen ob du
wirklich so gut laufen kannst du
behauptest aber ich habe eine spitze
zunge so so
eine minute später für mich drin ich
brauche dieses hin und her
waschbecken und wannen muss mich kann
machen ich glaube
es tut der ganzen serie und den ganzen
fortschritten bisher nicht so gut dass
diese drei neuen leute mit dabei sind
wieder neue kraft ich bin zum ersten mal
sprachlos ja oder bei deinem ganzen
abschluss und ich will jede sekunde mit
der genießen
du weißt dass ich dich von anfang an
macht mit 291 im resort steckt francesca
ihre wir ganz klar ab ja also die neuen
sind ja nicht mal ansatzweise und
francesca also francesca du bist
einmalig kennt verband sein muss ich bin
die schaffte hier
[Musik]
die dralle finn selbstvertrauen und sich
haben es echt unfassbar der blick dabei
sagt auch einfach alles ich mag dich so
wie du bist
bis hin zu schnulzig für mich sein
chester wird ihre krone als königin des
resorts nicht so leicht aufgeben als
reinigendes warum bist du die königin
eigentlich sollten ja so könige mit
einem guten beispiel vorangehen von
statt bisher jedem jährige brauchte ich
sollte echt mal nach einer kooperation
und fragen der ila keine kooperation
nicht sein
in drei fremde auftauchen und einen
schwan klauen wollen sollte man die
situation vielleicht nicht noch mit
alkohol und tanz anfachen
ich sehe schwarz für das eine die
verfolger ich bin nicht mehr der neue
auch andere drei neulinge und eine tolle
nacht
okay die spuren auf eine tolle nacht
alles aus plastik
das war jetzt darum ich schaue mir das
jetzt so kritsch vor mit zu den ganzen
kameras und sogar mit spaß lebens und
wir beobachten das blabla zehn
kameraleute drum herum fahren da wird
hat einen herzinfarkt antalya system
madison sieht gut aus ich bin gespannt
was da passiert und er habe es aber was
haben sie da eigentlich alles und vor
allem matthew was hat der sich denn
gedacht so heute will ich mal so
aussehen wie ein richtiger vollidiot wo
kriege ich die meldelisten auf jeden
fall roben francescas mit 10 absolute
traumfrau
aber klar ist auch hübsch und wir
verstehen uns als ich etwas geht auch
kummer unsere beiden turteltäubchen
rugbyspieler und die regeln brechen
und dann gibt es noch nicht
ich sitze hier mit einer kuh
wenn ich jemanden mag will ich auch
besteht tun kann was ich will
was ist das promi talk denkst du bist
der himmel oder was ist das für eine
komische party ich hoffe er öffnet sich
das ist eine sichere sache
ein vogel der sich an einem ast festhält
kann nicht
[Musik]
ja
und mensch der nicht atmet stirbt was
hat das jetzt mit der situation zu tun
der wahre test ist loszulassen ich
schätze aus ganz hessen
matthews und man da fällt dann
allerdings mit seite euch muss das hart
sein
ich hatte echt spaß ich habe einen guten
rat
was kommt jetzt vogel der auf dem boden
knallt stirbt jetzt bist du kannst
kämpfen weglaufen oder es laufen lassen
ich sag dazu
einfach nur
ich glaube ich gehe mal ja ich glaube
das ist besser
ich glaube die mildesten
unter dem entgegen wie ein bisschen was
anderes vorgestellt und ich weiß auch
nicht ob der mensch wieder komplett ohne
substanzen inhaliert sitzt ich glaube
ich muss nicht ganz nüchtern es was für
eine scheiße gelabert es ist die einer
dieser filme wie sind man sie los in 10
sekunden ja hast du sehr gut aber auch
wieder die müdigkeit am samstagmorgen
ich meine videos um 49 auf
split/second slater shirts da bin ich
wieder im moment was haben glory und
corey denn vor bringen wir tanzen tanzen
das ist ganz leicht so
es ist ganz leicht
fehlt nur noch dass ein bisschen
überflügelt die sich am ast festhalten
reden oder über rugby welle dass auch
neue story und ich haben viel gemeinsam
und intellektuell nicht so klug zu sein
gehört dazu ich bin stark wie chloe das
wirklich immer wieder selbst bestätigt
dass sie einfach wirklich astronomisch
er hat ein auge auf mich geworfen aber
wegen der regeln sind alle etwas nervös
ja aber warum habt ihr da alle so
glitzer hängen hier auch wieder da in
der fresse beim apple hatte hätte auch
diese komischen holy partys immer
spanien kämpfen dann schmeißen der
farben hoch wo du siehst aus wie ein
regenbogen
ja ich hatte auch nie freunde mit den
ich gegangen wäre hätte sein können
das war halt auch noch mal und ich
schlafe auf den boden nicht auf dem
stimmt das ist ganz okay die machen das
mit dem verlad ich mache das schon seit
zwei wochen david gefällt mir und wenn
mir jemand gefällt krieg ich den ok wie
machen die das real top mit dem platz
wir haben sechs betten
und sind
doch es kommt hin kommt es ihm nicht
diesen 13 leute
da müssen dann ein bett drei schlafen
auf die mädels sind nett und die jungs
sind super cool
ok gaddafi hatte harry was hast du denn
dafür stelle im gesicht also sorry aber
was haben sie sich denn dabei alle
gedacht heute schminken wir uns mal alle
wie die milchstraße oder oder wie ich
habe bemerkt dass keiner von euch durch
die neuankömmlinge in versuchung geraten
ist warum ist beweist die stärke einer
verbindung ja ganz kurze frage seit wann
ist an jessica schwarz war die mich
vorher was ich vor der weiße verpackung
damit habt ihr euch eine nacht zu zweit
in der provinz mitverdient mary suite
ist der bisher grösste keuschheit test
für euch mal das wieso habe ich denn
eigentlich schon wieder gänsehaut weil
die eine private suite kriegen nicht
halt den sinn nicht
von dieser private zwei die tür fällt
nix machen
genau das gleiche werde mit den anderen
da schlafen würden die gemeinsame zeit
ist eine chance euch noch besser
kennenzulernen so sehen die dauer
ablenkungen mein herz rast naja ihr habt
halt also es wird halt nichts passiert
und er macht zudem ron jordan buch und
nehmt einfach alles mit was geht und
kostet sind truppe nachher vier
millionen euro eine denkweise hat sich
um 180 grad gedreht so höre aber eine
lange die usa zu teilen ist die größte
versuchung aller zeiten ich danke danke
lana der blick von harry sagt auch alles
ich hoffe einfach wirklich dass ihr dort
eurer versuchung standhalten und dass
ihnen nichts miteinander haben werdet es
bringt euch wirklich was wir wissen das
ist eine sexuelle anziehung zwischen uns
gibt
dies folgt aus am konstanz besser
kennenzulernen und kein geld zu
verpassen auch wenn wir es wollen
was habt ihr damit euren boom sternchen
sternsinger auf wunsch bestellt hier
plane hat francesca bekehrt die tür ist
nun offen
okay die tür ist auch es kann losgehen
meine lieben freunde die private suite
ist geöffnet für francesca und harry was
dort drin passieren wir schauen wir uns
alle in der nächsten episode luca
reagiert auf tortur händel an meine
lieben folge
ja ihr seid nicht meine lieben freunde
seid meine lieben freunde und meiner
nächsten rektor handle werde ich dann
auch hoffentlich den eid schreckenstat
haben ich habe meinen leider wirklich
irgendwie verloren also ich habe dir
nicht gefunden ich wollte es eigentlich
heute schon machen allerdings habe ich
meinen neuen bestellt der soll
übermorgen ankommen am montag und am
dienstag soll die nächste folge kommen
das heißt es sieht gut aus wenn ihr
diese frage nicht verpassen wollt dann
klickt mal ganz schnell hier oben auf
den smiley darauf meine lieben freunde
schon wieder folge nicht dumm
ich beantworte ich weiß es ist dumm bin
liegt hier oben drauf dann könnte meinen
kanal kostet aber den verpasst keine
videos während die letzte reaction vor
mir auf die urteile verpasst haben
solltet ihr darauf dann könnt ihr euch
das ganze nochmal anschauen da seht ihr
wie die neuen leute aufregen so gekommen
sind allerdings sehen wir uns dann erst
mal in drei tagen wieder